bonjour à tous autour de moi parler des
futurs samsung galaxy s love et rs
[Musique]
on en sait plus on a eu énormément
d'informations ces derniers temps sur
les sur ce que pourrait être en tout cas
les futurs samsung galaxy s 9 est 9 plus
d'ailleurs vous avez déjà fait une vidéo
pour vous en parler et vous donner
toutes les spécifications techniques
qu'on avait en tout cas en notre
possession toutes les rumeurs
de ce point de vue a d'ailleurs la vidéo
est ici je vous invite à aller la voir
on a maintenant plus d'infos sur les
fonctionnalités de ce smartphone sur ce
qu'il va avoir dans le ventre
est ce qu'on va pouvoir faire avec avant
toute chose je vous demandais un petit
service vous savez bien évidemment que
je suis présent sur youtube sinon vous
ne regardiez pas cette vidéo jusque là
c'est très logique mais je suis aussi
présent sur d'autres réseaux sociaux
instagram twitter snap châtrices book
alors vous demande pas de me joindre par
tous mais c'est vrai que gars du contenu
qui est des fois publié un petit peu
différemment sur certains réseaux
sociaux et notamment sur instagram donc
je vous invite à aller voir tous les
liens de mes réseaux sociaux qui sont
dans la description en dessous à vous
abonner à ce que vous souhaitez et
instagram en particulier ça me ferait
très plaisir
voilà pour cette petite aparté je vous
remercie énormément et maintenant on va
continuer le sud de la vidéo parce que
vous allez voir qu'il ya plein de choses
hyper intéressantes qui vont arriver et
notamment sans ce samsung galaxy sur ces
samsung galaxy ace n'a ps n'a plus on
sait déjà à quelle date pour présenter
ses nouveaux modèles ce sera le 25
février de cette année à 18 heures la
veille de l'ouverture du mwc le mobile
world congress qui a lieu tous les ans à
barcelone alors justement que j'ai reçu
mon invitation pour pouvoir
effectivement être présents à
l'événement je serai au bail le world
congress en 2018 donc je pourrais
prendre ce samsung c'est samsung galaxy
s 9,9 plus en avant première dans les
mains au pouvoir effectivement vous dire
ce que j'en pense donc bien évidemment
je vous invite toujours à vous abonner à
rester connectés parce que on va
toujours en parler beaucoup plus
beaucoup mieux et dès que j'aurai dans
les mains je pourrais vous dire ce que
j'en pense
avec l'agitation du la confirmation du
slogan du samsung galaxy s 9 c'est
l'appareil photo aurait imaginé donc on
va très bien dans quelle direction va
aller à samsung avec ce smartphone très
clairement la photographie l'appareil
photo et la vidéo va être énormément mis
en avant de toute façon on sait très
bien qu'aujourd'hui les smartphones dont
les utilisent pour téléphoner symphorien
pour des applications donc gérer
d'autres quotidiens que ce soit des jeux
chose comme ça et pour faire des
souvenirs des photos des vidéos lac
centrale de samsung en 2018 était déjà
de cibler les créateurs de contenus qui
sont des prescripteurs pour pouvoir
effectivement toucher le maximum de
personnes sur la photo et sur la vidéo
c'est dans ce sens effectivement qu'ils
ont sorti une caméra une nouvelle caméra
à 360 l'année dernière et dans ce sens
également effectivement qui veulent
démocratiser la vr donc ça c'est des
choses on en reparlera un petit peu plus
tard il continue vraiment à aller dans
ce sens à travailler autour de leurs
caméras autour de leurs appareils photos
alors qu'est ce qui va avoir cet
appareil photo bien a priori on devrait
avoir effectivement pour la photographie
une double ouverture 1.5 2.4 ça ça
serait une première sur un smartphone
d'avoir effectivement une ouverture
réglable donc en fonction de vos
conditions de lumière vous pourriez
vraiment vous adapter sans forcément
aller taper dans les iso alors je vais
pas rentrer dans le côté un peu de
technique parce que tu as forcément tout
de suite rébarbatif mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que plus vous descendez le
nombre au niveau de l'ouverture et mieux
vous aller capter la lumière qui fait
que une ouverture en 1.5 sera bien
meilleur en faible luminosité qu'une
perte sûrs en 2.4 pour une ouverture
11.5 par exemple vous avez pas besoin de
monter énormément les iso vous restez
sur un iso 800 à voir à tester à thonon
là pour peut imaginer effectivement de
prendre des photos de nuit et vous
devriez avoir un super rendu ça c'est
vraiment un point extrêmement positif et
on va vraiment que samsung avait déjà
des appareils photo qui était une super
qualité mais là ils vont encore plus
loin
raillé pour sa jolie pouces on parle du
slogan des faux souvenirs qu'en 2017 le
slogan pour les ai suivis ts fit plus
est est une box sur fun donc on voyait
très bien qu'ils annoncé le bord à bord
ces grands écrans qu'ils ont ouvert une
voie là avec l'appareil photo aurait
imaginé à mon avis ils vont aller plus
loin encore dans la photographie et
continuer avec prescripteurs dans ce
domaine qu'est ce qu'on voit aussi avec
toutes ces rumeurs et toutes les
informations qui sont révélés les fuites
qui sont sortis on voit que les samsung
s 9 et 16 9 plus auront sensiblement le
même design que les suites et et suit
plus la différence on devrait avoir des
petites bandes en haut et en bas un peu
plus fine alors sale joue
grand chose c'est du point de détail
mais au final sur un appareil ça peut
être très sympa confirmation pour le dos
de l'appareil on va bien avoir le
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui sera
bien positionnée en dessous du capteur
photo pour le snof et des capteurs photo
pour le s le plus d'ailleurs on en
extrait vidéo d'une prise en main de ce
samsung galaxy s 9 fake ou pas c'est
compliqué à dire mais en tout cas ce que
ça démontre c'est le réel engouement
autour de ce produit y aurait eu aussi
une potentielle fuite du fond d'écran du
fond d'écran du samsung galaxy s 9 alors
ça a priori c'est un fake mais ça
s'inspire réellement cliqua de l'univers
de samsung pour ses smartphones
justement on parle de fonctionnalités il
devrait y en avoir une qui serait hyper
intéressante en terme de déverrouillage
samsung il est encore plus loin avec une
reconnaissance biométrique hybride
c'est-à-dire une reconnaissance faciale
par infrarouge mais également un scanner
d'iris ce qui fait que vous auriez les
deux quelle que soit la luminosité
ambiante que ce soit la nuit que ce soit
le jour vous pourriez déverrouiller
votre appareil en toute sécurité
et justement cette techno pourra
effectivement aller plus loin et on
devrait aller vers des emoji animée ça
vous rappelle probablement quelque chose
c'est ce qu'a fait apple avec ses
animaux ji alors là où apple bride un
peu l'utilisation des animaux ji
uniquement aux i b sage samsung pourrait
l'ouvrir et on pourrait totalement
l'imaginer les retrouver sont les
réseaux sociaux pouvoir les exploiter
dans différentes applications est allé
plus loin
donc ça aussi gros point positif
autre fonctionnalité révélé sur les
samsung galaxy s 9,9 plus c'est la
possibilité de jouer sur la profondeur
de champ et sur le focus des stickers
petit mot sur le papier on comprend pas
forcément l'utilité mais en
réfléchissant avantage j'imagine en tout
cas que ça présage vraiment une
évolution en termes de réalité augmentée
c'est des choses qui concernent plus les
développeurs parce que vous vous avez
pas vous amuser à rajouter du flou la
profondeur de champ sur un stickers
mais d'un point de vue d'un développeur
c'est un vrai sens c'est à dire pouvoir
complètement joué sur une profondeur de
champ
lorsqu'on imagine là dessus c'est
vraiment l'intégration de la réalité
augmentée à ces nouveaux appareils
autre rumeur qui court la présence d'une
double lecteur de carte sim sur cet
appareil c'est vrai qu'en france on
avait la présence d'un lecteur de carte
sim et d'un lecteur de cartes microsd
mais pas d'un double lecteur de carte
sim par contre on peut retrouver chez
samsung dans d'autres pays on devrait
pouvoir le retrouver sur ces samsung
galaxy s 9 et s9 plus l'intérêt d'avoir
une double coeur signe de touche pas
forcément tout le monde mais pour les
professionnels pour avoir une ligne trop
humide perso ça un vrai sens et lorsque
vous vous déplacez à l'étranger ça peut
aussi être bien si vous n'avez pas un
forfait internationale d'abord une carte
sim locales pour éviter d'exposer votre
forfait la contrepartie de tous âges de
toutes ses fonctionnalités de toutes ses
caractéristiques techniques
c'est l'évolution des prix s'attendent à
ce que le prix reste sensiblement le
même 809 euros
909 euros a priori il pourrait prendre
10 % d'augmentation pour finir à 889
euros et 999 euros
on prend des pincettes de toute façon ça
ne saoule n'a pas intérêt à ce que c'est
flagship arrive au même prix que sa
gamme note ce qu'il y aurait quand même
un certain déséquilibre ont pas non plus
augmenté à du tam aeternam le prix la
gamme de donc pour l'instant on prend
des pincettes bien évidemment la grande
innovation dans son smartphone ce serait
l appareil photo ce que ça suffirait à
justifier une augmentation du prix pour
l'instant c'est un petit peu difficile à
dire qu'on va très très bien avec ces
fuites et ces rumeurs c'est que de toute
façon samsung va aller encore plus loin
au niveau de la qualité de vos photos ce
que comme je le disais en préambule
effectivement samsung travaille sur des
caméras de réalité dire que ça c'est la
deuxième version il ya une première
version celle là on voit effectivement
qui joue sur la portabilité sur ce fait
de la tenir à la main de se balader fils
mecque de la vierge partout donc l'idée
de samsung c'est de coller des caméras
partout c'est d'être innovant dans ce
domaine là pareil du côté de la vère on
retrouve effectivement certains cas du
htc on a dû à ces en a pas mal de choses
mais en produits hyper optimisé pour
votre smartphone samsung c'est pareil
chez les concurrents il y en a
quelques-uns mais il y en a pas
énormément et vu la force de frappe de
samsung on va très bien qu'ils veulent
continuer dans cette dynamique là
s'imposer du point de vue de la
photographie grand public touché les
créateurs de contenus qui sont
prescripteurs et qui vont relayer les
tendances à des grandes marques et
autres points qui pourraient aussi
arrivée qui pourrait être intéressant
c'est l'évolution du decs alors
effectivement samsung avec son insu de
suite plus ont lancé le
ex c'est-à-dire pour rappel ainsi vous
souvenez pas c'est un espèce de petit
bois qui dans lequel vous branchez votre
smartphone qui est relié lui un clavier
et un écran et votre smartphone vous
sert en gros de l'unité centrale
vous pouvez l'utiliser pour toutes vos
tâches de bureautique à la maison
quotidienne en tout cas ce qui fait
qu'on n'a plus qu'une seule unité qui
vous sert partout lorsque vous vous
déplacez le smartphone dans la poche
lorsque tu as la maison le smartphone
vous sert également de coeur de votre
vie numérique on voit effectivement
aussi que c'est un projet qui a été mis
en avant par razer sur son projet linda
qui était présenté au cs cette année
donc on est vraiment dans cette
dynamique là élan pourrait retrouver
index d'ex pad qui serait un évolution
du decs on pourrait de plus branché sur
le pod restée dessus ça leur chercherait
par induction et en même temps il y
aurait une communication de
l'information par un système sans fil et
qui vous paraît très utilisé comme unité
centrale
donc voilà un peu toutes les
informations que j'ai pu glaner à droite
à gauche sur les rumeurs sur les suites
au tour de ceux de ses futurs samsung
galaxy s mais face la puce donc je vous
invite à rester que l'été parce que de
toute façon comme je vous le dis je
serai présent au mwc à barcelone
je vais le voir en exclusivité je vais
prendre dans les mains en exclusivité
donc je vous invite comme d'hab à me
laisser des jolies pousse à vous abonner
à rester là parce qu'on va parler encore
plus en forme ou du high tech
j'ai plein plein plein plein de choses à
vous dire que les smartphones l'attesté
qui sont dans les cartons là où j'ai pas
encore eu le temps de m'en occuper mais
j'ai plein plein plein de trucs donc
rester connecté j'ai encore des vidéos
du cng alary pour janvier partout donc
ça dégueulasse je n'en peux plus merci à
vous êtes les meilleurs je vous dis à
très bientôt pour eux soyez sages portez
vous bien et à bientôt
[Musique]